the most controversial movie of the year
the interview is As Dead As Kim Jong-un
in that leak scene from the interview
I'd say that's a spoiler alert but it's
only a spoiler if you can watch the
movie and today Sony canceled the
Christmas Day release of the interview
Mark um this this Cam's on the heel on
the heels earlier today of a bunch of
theaters chains many of them in America
that said they weren't going to screen
the movie I got to ask you know a
cliched hacky question but everything we
found out today have the terrorists now
won they've won for now look we still
don't know who did it I think it's the
North Koreans a lot of people disagree
with me but whoever did it they didn't
want this movie shown it's now not going
to be shown and I think it's incumbent
upon everybody in the country whether
you're in the media the movie business
politician whoever you are if you care
about Freedom we're going to have to
figure this out and and the other thing
is we got to get to the bottom of who
did it have to right but let's be clear
about one thing it's interesting these
two things are going to get conflated in
a minute right which is that the hack
raises all kinds of problems right
stolen material should the pr report
about it we've talked about that on this
show this is a separate thing it's
connected right I mean if it was the if
it's the same perpetrators but what has
happened here is threats had been issued
whether the hack had happened or not
terrorists could have threatened to
attack movie theaters where this movie
was going to show up and that is I think
the thing that's driving the movies
theaters first the cinema chains to
First shut this down and now the the
company yesterday I predicted on the
show that I thought Sony would face this
very quickly they cannot Sony even
though it's not their fault they cannot
allow a movie to open that presents a
significant chance of anyone getting
hurt already faced so much legal
liability they already as we said
ylo so they couldn't risk people's lives
even if the even if the law enforcement
sources talking to them say what they're
saying to the Press which is they didn't
see this as a credible threat it's it's
too big a risk the law enforcement has
got to get the bottom of this again all
the subsidiary issues that you mentioned
in this country if a major corporation
is hacked we have to be able to get to
the bottom of it catch the people even
if it's not a deterrent we've got to
send the message that we won't tolerate
that as a country I agree with that my
hope going towards this Christmas I want
to see this movie um because I think
it's going to be very funny and what my
hope is is that between now and
Christmas Day the authorities will
apprehend the people who are making the
threats we appr will know who the hacker
was and that Sony will be able to
reverse this decision and open this
movie on Christmas Day that would be the
best Christmas present we could get make
it available online for like 250 I'd pay
it i' I'd pay more is that a good
solution well it might be a solution it
might be a solution I mean it be
interesting to know if that that would
actually address a bunch of business
model challenges the movie industry has
but I think you know day and dat release
put it on uh pay-per-view maybe that's
the answer to this thing so that freedom
loving Americans can watch Seth Rogan
and James Franco blow up Kim Jung noon's
head now the buzz of the movie isn't
very good I care this would be a much
I'm just saying it'd be a much different
debate if it were a masterpiece well
maybe maybe it would different it's
still the fundamental issues are still
theat theaters felt like they could get
away with not showing it well maybe
except for I do think that look once you
start to have threats against movie
theaters you really just you're just not
going anywhere